and what about future movies starring us  Stern show members we've had Ronnie who  got in your movie you had Gary in a  movie and Sal appeared and uh oh I know  he appeared in some sitcom with you oh  there you go there you go it seems that  our show is getting a lot of work here  um you've been a great farm team for the  happy Madison that was Ronnie to work  with fantastic he add a lot to the movie  I know he was nervous he didn't want to  disappoint you  you know listen you had a big career and  he was solid man he didn't look nervous  at all went very strong Long Island I  saw strong long on I thought when I saw  it I said you know it I don't know how  many takes they had to do that's not my  business I don't forget all right there